hey what's up guys so the purpose of
this video is for you to ask any
questions you'd like to have answered
regarding Dark Souls 2 so head down to
the comment section below and ask me the
biggest question you have or just the
first thing that comes to mind try to be
creative to think of something that you
think everyone would like answered
there's a little information about the
law that's leaked over time there's
quite a lot of PvP experiences from the
beta and personally I have a lot of
experience from PvE so I can tell you
about my favorite weapons my experiences
how the game felt and what I'm hoping
for but I really just want to know what
you're interested in personally I've
played more than 10 hours of the beta
and the TGS demo respectively in the
beta there were two bosses and a lot of
enemies
coupled with invasions and summoning in
the TGS demo the game was polished to
give you a complete Dark Souls
experience with ambushes traps and
shortcuts and on top of all this I keep
track of all the news that comes out so
I have a pretty good idea of where the
game is headed obviously I can't answer
everything but leave your questions and
I'll answer everything uncomfort and
about and there's actually a lot more
information than you'd expect so in the
next few weeks look forward to an answer
video as well as a couple of other
videos summing up everything we know
about the PvE the PvP and the law but
these videos have to be approved by
Namco so you might not see them for a
few weeks if you have any questions you
can't wait to ask then hit me up on
Twitter at Vardy video and I'll try to
get back to you there so the focus of
this video is actually a comment section
I don't know why still listening to me
talk so make sure you're active down
there if you can't think of your own
question then scroll through and thumb
up the good questions if you're still
listening to me speak for some reason
I'm just going to drop some buzzwords
and inspire some good questions if
you're having a hard time here we go law
prequel sequel it's totally a sequel PvP
balanced fair difficulty summoning
invading dying shortcuts hidden areas
secrets speed running first playthrough
ps3 ps4 Xbox 360 Xbox one sucks PC
master-race
and that'll do it hopefully you have a
good question by now so let me know
choose guys I'll see you in the next one
when the old one was awakened the deep
folk spread of the world and from the
folk came demons a horde that swept
through volaterrae and brought
civilization to its knees the old one is
a bottomless pit of nothingness with an
insatiable appetite for souls but it
cannot collect souls itself imagine a
tree with roots leaves and a core the
old one is the trunk the core of the
tree it spreads its roots into the lands
full of humans and the Foulke drains
their souls as a creatures soul
diminishes they become soul starved
paranoid insane and full of Rage the mad
attack the sane and chaos prevails the
only way to stay saying